[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
régionales et sur tv5 monde voici tout
de suite les titres de l'actualité de ce
journal
depuis plusieurs jours une grève
générale s'est vite en martinique et en
guadeloupe contre l'obligation vaccinale
des soignants sur place une équipe
devient atv de nos partenaires est allé
prendre la température de cette grève
dans l'actualité une cinquième vague de
covile 19 s'apprête à déferler sur la
france vous savez peut-être une nouvelle
solution pour lutter contre tous les
types de virus a fait son apparition nos
reporters sont allés rencontrer
l'entreprise nano qui qui nous en parle
dans un instant la semaine prochaine et
lancer la 37e campagne hivernale des
restos du coeur les caméras de wéo tv
nos partenaires dans le nord ont pu
pénétrer dans l'un des entrepôts de
l'association à quelques jours des
distributions et vous le verrez toute
l'équipe est déjà sur le pont
dans ce journal également vous ferez la
connaissance grâce à nos confrères de la
dépêche d'un heureux inventeur de 14 ans
lauréat du célèbre concours lépine il
nous fera découvrir son robot aussi
ingénieux qu'ecolo vous le verrez et
puis en fin de journal c'est miss
provence et nous espérons la future miss
monde 2021 qui s'est confié aux
journalistes de la provence nos
confrères sur place
pour ouvrir ce journal alors que se
précise peut être une cinquième vague du
virus je vous le disais en titre en
martinique le mouvement contre
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants et
le pass annie terre d'ailleurs se durcit
loïc régis et diana françois eudoxie
devient atv sont allés à la rencontre de
grévistes excédé rien
une circulation encore fluide avant
l'arrivée du convoi une opération
molokaï menée par divers organismes
avec quatre points de départ différent
les effets sur la circulation sont à
sellette et sur le trajet quelques
soutiens se manifeste alors je suis
favorable à 100%
oui parce que
j'estime que le pass obligatoire faut
pas faire ça chacun choisit d'être
vaccinées ou non c'est un choix à faire
autre mobilisation à la pointe des
grives cette fois le port de fort de
france est bloqué aucun camion ne peut
quitter ou accéder à la plateforme
depuis ce matin un site important
volontairement ciblé dans les
manifestants c'est le point névralgique
du pays c'est celle économique mais
c'est juste pour attirer l'attention des
élus du gouvernement pour dire que
l'obligation vaccinale que nous sommes
contre l'obligation vaccinale et le
passé ni terre et aussi pour la cherté
de la vie bien sûr il faut qu'on se
prénommait parce que on ne veut pas on
ne va pas attendre qu'un bidon de gaz
arrive à 50 euros courants puissent se
décider à se mobiliser cette action
nommée opération convergence s'est
conclu devant la rs en milieu de matinée
la demande reste la même depuis des
semaines l'annulation de l'obligation
vaccinale et non un report nous c'est le
troisième report mais un report laisse
le stress l'angoissé sur les agents ne
veut pas de cette épée de damoclès sur
la tête on veut que la loi soit annulée
ou une dérogation doit être mis en place
pour les antilles ça a été fait par le
passé avec le chlordécone ça plaide fait
cette fois-ci combinaison une opération
d'envergure une autre mobilisation de ce
type pourrait avoir lieu la semaine
prochaine plusieurs organisations
syndicales appellent à un grand
rassemblement le 22 novembre
voilà alors que cette cinquième vague de
covile 19 s'apprête sans doute à défiler
sur la france une nouvelle solution pour
lutter contre tous les types de virus a
fait son apparition il s'agit du photo
need de l'entreprise nan auxi elle
utilise l'énergie générée par la lumière
naturelle ou artificielle pour
décomposer les microbes et comme vous le
découvrez sur ces images tournées à
villenave d'ornon environ il suffit de
la pulvériser et toutes les surfaces
sont protégés pendant près d'un an
voilà puis sans transition comme je vous
le disais dans les titres la semaine
prochaine des luttes la trente septième
campagne des restos du coeur alors dans
les entrepôts les bénévoles s'activent
pour que tout soit prêt comme a pu le
constater et amiens vous allez voir
agathe poulets de loué aux tv la chaîne
de la voix du nord
l approche des premières distributions
du resto du coeur de la somme didier
passe en revue les colis collectés
depuis octobre je suis en train de
mettre nos palettes en place pour faire
une préparation la semaine prochaine
donc là plusieurs personnes
cette année 40 tonnes de produits ont
été collectés et donnés par des
entreprises françaises et européennes
dans cet entrepôt de 1800 mètres carrés
on retrouve des colis alimentaires mais
également des produits hygiéniques mais
beaucoup de produits bébé de couches
du les
70% l alimentaire au moins 80 80 %
supplémentaires depuis fin octobre la
campagne d'hiver des inscriptions pour
les personnes accueillies au sein du
resto du coeur a débuté selon le siège
national de l'association une
augmentation de 15 % est attendue avec
de nouveaux profils conséquence à la
crise sanitaire des personnes qu'on ne
voyait pas précédemment 1 comme les
jeunes c'est vraiment un phénomène
nouveau si vous voulez puis à l'autre
bout du spectre j'irai il ya aussi les
personnes âgées on a aussi ce type de
personnes un peu dans les campagnes qui
n'ont pas beaucoup de moyens et c'est
peut-être la population la plus
difficile parce que quand vous avez un
certain âge pouvoir dire voilà j'ai pas
assez d'argent pour finir mon moi et je
vais vouloir c'est toujours difficile de
pousser la porte des restos les
inscriptions sont ouvertes durant toute
la campagne d'hiver jusqu'en mars
prochain quant aux distributions elles
débuteront à partir du 23 novembre dans
les 35 cents du département de la somme
volée maintenant coup de projecteur sur
une autre belle initiative il s'agit de
celle du collectif montpelliérain des
livres eux qui livre des repas chauds
aux sans abri et qui fête ce mois ci sa
toute première année d'existence vous
voyez sur ces images de l'insee wham o o
devient occitanie tous ces bénévoles
rassemblés qui ont permis à ce jour de
distribuer près de dix mille repas un
grand bravo à eux en tout cas
voilà et puis dans l'actualité un
inventeur de 14 ans il s'appelle sasha
comme je vous l'annonçais dans les
titres il vient d'être primé au célèbre
concours lépine pour le clean bottes un
robot capable de ramasser des déchets
totalement en autonomie
manon aussi de la dépêche il a rencontré
chez lui à villefranche de lauragais en
haute garonne regardez j'ai pas
réellement de base en programmation
électronique j'ai cherché des solutions
sur internet etc au fur et à mesure des
problèmes que je rencontrais il ya à peu
près un an et demi de développement pour
le prototype 1 et je compte deux ans
deux ans et demi de développement pour
le prototype de ce robot pourra détecter
quasiment tous les déchets qui sont
généralement présents en ville y compris
les mégots de cigarettes donc il va
détecter les déchets ni ramassé il les
met directement dans ce bac de tri
intégré à l'arrière
direction maintenant dans ce journal
l'ille-et-vilaine et plus précisément
saint-sulpice-des-landes une commune de
900 habitants dont le maire n'a que 27
ans victor lhermitte a été élu le 28
octobre dernier et comme vous allez le
voir dans ce reportage signé philippe
berthaut de tvr à rennes il est vraiment
sur tous les fronts
serge legendre et victor lhermitte
l'ancien et le nouveau maire de saint
sulpice des landes une commune de 900
habitants au sud de bain de bretagne qui
se retrouvent administré par un jeune
homme de 27 ans est pris de gestion
publique l'important je crois c'est
d'être entouré et surtout dans vos
petites communes parce que les rôles de
l'euro de l'exécutif n'est pas politique
c'est vraiment de l'opérationnel pur
donc il faut être entouré et c'est le
cas on a quatre adjoints aujourd'hui
donc on est on est cinq à
à gérer la commune je suis pas tout seul
et l'agenda du maire risquent la
saturation si l'on considère que le
nouvel édile est aussi président d'un
groupe de quatre sociétés dont la
première a été fondée par son grand-père
l'une de ses activités consistent à
acheter et restructurer des entreprises
comme ici à passer spécialisée dans la
fabrication de produits chimiques et
après la réunion de coordination ce
matin ses visites de chantier est suivi
de travaux pour la remise aux normes du
site c'est la deûle à lui qu'il faut les
respecter c'est que la peinture doit
être alimentaire au sol on a investi
dans une salle de conditionnement
alimentaire ont daigné finalement tout
ce bâtiment l'alimentaire qu'une chambre
chaude et une salle de conditionnement
et monsieur le maire compte aussi
développer sa commune qui verra bientôt
sortir de terre un projet de lotissement
de 50 maisons de quoi redynamiser la
démographie et les activités il sera
peut-être un jour lui aussi maire en
tout cas si vous avez un collégien à la
maison le casse-tête de la recherche
d'un stage d'observation a peut-être
déjà commencé pour vous dans la loire a
été lancé une toute nouvelle plateforme
pour justement aider nos chers à nos a
trouvé ce sacro-saint stage devenu
obligatoire une idée qui pourrait sans
doute faire des petits dans d'autres
régions explications de céline ersilia
de tl7 la télévision de la loire
en quelques clics une centaine d'offres
de stage de 3e est proposé aux élèves de
collèges connectés ici ils peuvent
consulter et déposé une candidature
anonyme
l'idée de garantir aux jeunes un accès
équitable à ces stages obligatoires et
d'éviter que certains se retrouvent à
faire des stages peu intéressants
souvent trouvé dans un périmètre
familial restreint c'est dommage quoi ça
leur ça ne leur ouvre pas l'esprit comme
ce que j'aimerais moi pouvoir leur
proposer leur sens vraiment l'ouverture
au milieu professionnel à la vie de
demain imaginez ce que ça peut être que
d'aller travailler le matin de se lever
le matin et avec plaisir et d'aller
travailler dans un endroit qui nous
plaît même si elle est contrainte même
si à des concessions à faire sur le site
déjà 118 places disponibles plusieurs
entreprises s'engagent dans le
dispositif là ces pme incite ses
adhérents à prendre ces jeunes
stagiaires et pour que l'accueil de ces
jeunes ne soient pas une contrainte pour
l'entreprise il ya certains trucs adopté
ce qui est important c'est fixer des
objectifs assez jeune observe et sain
c'est ce qui va faire toute la
différence
si vous allez être avec nous quatre ou
cinq jours eh bien on va vous donner des
petits challenge sur des sujets
importants les différents métiers de
notre boîte quelles sont les activités
de notre entreprise qu'est ce qui est
curieux vous ne vous attendiez pas à ce
que ça se passe comme ça racontez nous
en fait le plus important va être de
créer un temps de narration à la fin du
stage que le jeune raconte ce qu'il a
vécu si l'employeur valide une
candidature l'élève a 15 jours pour
confirmer les stages pourront également
se faire pendant les vacances scolaires
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
ils ne sont plus que cinq à exercer ce
beau métier en france de taillandier ces
artisans qui fabriquent des outils
tranchants et enzo maubert de lmtv
sarthe va nous emmener maintenant
rencontrer l'un d'entre eux il s'appelle
pascal turpin évite à montmirail dans la
sarthe regardez ce reportage
il faut une certaine couleur certaine
température des 100 degrés
donc si mais pas la bonne température
donc la bonne couleur
en fait vous allez mal d'efforts mais
vous n'allez plus quart des votes c'est
l'un des derniers représentants d'un
savoir faire ancestral
pascal turpin est l'un des cinq
thaïlandais français dans son atelier à
montmirail il fabrique couteau et épées
des pièces uniques qu'il conçoit imagine
avec une ambition qu elles se
transmettent et raconte des histoires et
couteau il y en a il en existe plein
mais l'important c'est de créer un
couteau avec une histoire à couteau bah
vous fait le mieux possible plus
professionnellement possible mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est de voir le sourire
de la personne qui va devenir
propriétaire de son couteau et la voilà
vous avez créé en fait on a fait notre
travail c'est d'apporter du moment où la
personne va acheter son couteau elle va
créer sa propre histoire avec son
couteau pascal a lancé son entreprise la
stèle montmirail en début d'année cela
lui permet de vendre ses couteaux dans
plusieurs enseignes de nature et
découvertes au mans et à paris pour
l'aider dans sa tâche il a également pu
embaucher une jeune apprentie d'avoir
été nommée taillandier d'armes c'est
vraiment
une fierté parce que c'est c'est quelque
chose qui qui se transmet et c'est donc
moi je suis fut très ravis de pouvoir
continuer à faire vivre ce métier parce
que c'est vraiment un métier qui
méritent de continuer de perdurer et
c'est le mois dernier un couteau
montmirail a été offert à brigitte
macron lors d'un salon à paris une
fierté pour l'artisan une belle
promotion pour notre département qui
sait demain l'opinel de la sarthe
deviendra peut-être un couteau de
référence sur les grandes tables
françaises
et puis à signaler cette fin de semaine
les éditions locales du magazine le
point avec marseille tout d'abord avec
cette une que vous voyez sur l'écran la
ruée sur marseille des dossiers dirigée
par audrey emery et valérie préfère avec
de nombreux articles dont un sur le
tramway argent débloqué mettra s'est
grippée comme l'écrit le point vous
verrez dans cette édition avec un
article également consacré au cinéma la
ville de marseille veut crever l'écran
des ambitions également du maire de
marseille le maire de marseille benoît
payan dans cette édition ainsi que pour
les épicuriens les détails sur ce qui se
passe à marseille en termes de
restauration le foot club chef devant
comme le titre cette édition du point la
ruée sur marseille
et puis l'édition locale consacré à
strasbourg également strasbourg
transports le grand bazar comme
l'indiquent nos confrères dans leur une
et dans cette édition coordonné par
valérie fait faire des papiers sur la
police et les transports à strasbourg
également dans le bas rhin une économie
à plusieurs vitesses un article très
intéressant ainsi qu'un article sur les
bains municipaux un lifting très réussie
pour ce joyau architectural de
strasbourg strasbourg transport le grand
bazar l'édition locale du point cette
semaine et puis on ouvre maintenant dans
ce journal une page littérature avec un
auteur à la trajectoire vous allez le
voir plutôt insolite après avoir
présenté les journaux télévisés de tf1
et d'antenne 2 le journaliste daniel
duigou a décidé de devenir prêtre et de
partir vivre dans un ermitage au maroc
il vient de publier aux éditions
salvator sept jours au désert son
premier roman inspiré de son étonnante
histoire christophe rigaud pour le grand
vite et des territoires la rencontre et
c'est un parcours peu banal que celui de
daniel duigou une carrière de
journaliste à tf1 antenne 2 et france 5
qu'il mène en parallèle avec une
activité de psychanalystes puis à 51 ans
il est ordonné prêtre dans le diocèse
d'amiens avant de quitter paris pour
partir vivre en ermite dans le sud
marocain
quand je présentais le journal je vivais
comme la plupart des journalistes à
à 100 km/heure et un moment donné où
vous n'avez plus le temps de penser de
réfléchir et j'avais envie à l'image de
charles de foucauld de faire rupture de
prendre de la distance et de partir dans
le désert pour justement avoir le temps
de me poser et de réfléchir et quand je
dis de réfléchir c'est à dire le temps
de penser ne pas laisser les autres
pensez à votre place pour son dixième
ouvrage sept jours au désert c'est à la
fiction que daniel duigou se frotte avec
une histoire qui n'est pas sans rappeler
son propre parcours l'histoire de ce
livre c'est la rencontre une rencontre
amoureuse entre un homme et une femme
une femme qui est ce une ancienne
étudiante qui est devenue religieuse et
qui s'interroge sur son avenir et puis
selon ancien professeur qui était
journaliste vedette et qui est devenu
prêtre et donc c'est une rencontre dans
le désert c'est à dire en prenant du
recul sur sur la vie pour s'interroger
comment construire mon avenir
sept jours au désert est une invitation
à s'interroger sur le sens de la vie
mais ce livre est surtout une ode à la
liberté une liberté que daniel duigou va
très vite retrouver en repartant pour
son ermitage dont le sud du maroc
voilà puis une page sportive dans ce
journal maintenant le mma ce sport de
combat qui mélange la boxe karaté la
lutte le judo le ju jitsu est en plein
essor en france on compte quelque
quarante mille licenciés aujourd'hui et
parmi eux un jeune bordelais de 20 ans
thomas glos qui multiplie les victoires
un portrait signé christophe rigaud
deux à trois fois par jour thomas
s'impose d entraînement physique
intensif
car dans sa discipline il ne faut pas se
ménager pour battre son adversaire
une cage deux combattants et trois
rounds de cinq minutes thomas glow
pratique le mma à haut niveau un sport
exigeant qui mélange la boxe le karaté
le ju jitsu ou encore la lutte des
combats violents qui peuvent
impressionner mais qui sont pourtant
très codifié et réglementée on n'a pas
le droit à tous les coups on a le droit
d'utiliser beaucoup de technique qui
viennent de des sports de combat mais
des techniques qui sont déjà autorisés
dans les autres sports de combat donc on
va pas par exemple remettre des doigts
dans les yeux des coûts dans les parties
des coûts dans la nuque ou à la gorge
tout ça c'est interdit et donc là c'est
d'aider des règles précises sa part est
violent mais en fait ça l'est beaucoup
moins que la plupart des sports de
combat
ça va le mma longtemps décrié a été
légalisé en france en 2020 une pratique
qui ne fait plus peur notamment au père
de thomas un ancien adepte de boxe thaï
on relativise quand on voit comment il
s'entraîne comment ils et comment il est
préparé comment les arbitres protègent
également l'intégrité des combattants
voilà on se dit voilà c'est un sport de
combat comme un autre coin pas pas plus
ni moins que la boxe ou aux pieds poings
ou d'autres arts martiaux l'image du mma
est en train de changer en france
notamment avec des combattants comme
thomas élève en école d'ingénieur de
grandes ambitions et la tête bien sur
les épaules va mais ambition c'est de
devenir champion du monde des matches
bien sûr donc pour l'instant ça c'est
l'ambition à long terme pour l'instant
un court terme je vais construire ma
carrière finir mes études et une fois
que mes études seront finis je pourrai
me consacrer à plein temps dans le mât
afin de performer de combattre contre
les meilleurs
une ambition légitime selon son
entraîneur qui croit très fort au
potentiel de thomas il est très
technique il est très technique dans le
sens où tout ce qu'il fait c'est prévu
il ya dans ces combats jusqu'à
maintenant tout cas il n'y a pas eu de
place au doute
je disais à 77 kg ça va vite maxime a
été durement touchée pour moi il ya
patron il a tout pour eux il a tout pour
l'élan en attendant d'être professionnel
thomas de l'eau continue de s'entraîner
dur d'enchaîner les combats et les
victoires
et puis ce week-end thomas blot poursuit
son ascension en compétition au canada
il combattra dans l'organisation bts
contre xavier nash nous lui souhaitons
bien sûr bonne chance
sport toujours dans ce journal en
attendant la sortie du prochain star
wars dont le tournage vient d'être
repoussée pourquoi ne pas marcher sur
les traces d'obi-wan kenobi en
s'essayant au sabre laser et c'est très
sérieux car la fédération française
d'escrimé a en effet reconnu
officiellement la discipline benjamin
delmas d'ailleurs de 7 à limoges s'est
rendu à l'entraînement de ses jedi en
herbe en nouvelles aquitaine attention
dark vador n'a qu'à bien se tenir
les jedi admob tout droit sorties des
films star wars une dizaine de padawan
venus apprendre le sabre laser lagunaire
et mouvements rate outillés même les
références
en tout cas il bougeait plus il était
moins playmobil mais avant de protéger
l'image et la galaxie il faut c'est
chauffer correctement car le sabre laser
n'est pas un jeu mais bel et bien un
sport ce type des scream d'abord il
s'est développé un peu sauvagement pas
forcément à limoges surtout après les
films qu'on connaît bien ça a été une
pratique sauvage ans aux états unis et
il ya cinq ans six ans la fédération
française d'escrimé c'est décidé c'est
dire c'est de l'escrim aussi et on va
mettre des règles
tout commence par l'apprentissage de la
technique les mouvements sont
chorégraphiés répété en binôme
l'objectif du maître jedi apprendre à
ses élèves des mouvements qu'ils
reproduiront au combat
un style de combat proche des arts
martiaux avec une véritable arme en main
les sabres lasers utilisés sont loin
d'être des jouets une lame en
polycarbonate qui peut très bien cassé
un doigt ou cas c'est même peut-être un
bras ou une jambe c'est très très dur
c'est la même
la même matière que les boucliers des
crs ou les lots des avions depuis 2018
le sabre laser et la 4e art de mesrine
comme le fleuret et le sabre et l'épée
on apprend des bases par et attaquer
mais en fait c'est une chorégraphe kipré
a pris feu après aller de plus en plus
vite pouvoir ensuite faire du spectacle
déco à limoges c'est jedi sont une
quinzaine comme partout en france leur
nombre est grandissant la discipline
compte désormais près de 1400 licenciés
prêt à défier les étoiles
et puis il y a une vie après une
carrière de sportif professionnel
la preuve sébastien germain 2 8 mont
blanc a retrouvé axel domont le champion
de cyclisme non pas sur un vélo vous
allez voir mais dans des vignes regardez
dans sa vie d'avant de coureur cycliste
professionnel
axel domont n'avait certainement pas le
temps de contempler les vignes le long
des routes mais aujourd'hui elles font
partie de son quotidien depuis le début
de l'année 2021 et la fin brutale de sa
carrière l'ancien coureur d'ag2r là
mondiale à s'élancer en tant que
négociant avec l'idée d'être un jour
vignerons gilles aux opportunités j'ai
rencontré des personnes tom ans nicolas
ferran et marielle sa femme du domaine
des côtes rousse j'habite pas très loin
de pas trop loin de chez eux leur
domaine et à la motte-servolex m'a dit
écoute tu trouves un peu de raison en
parallèle de ta carrière
et puis battu de vigny fichez moi je te
laisse faire je vais mais quelques
mètres carrés et puis là ma première
production donc celle de l'an dernier
qui est en bouteille aujourd'hui est
parti comme ça tout est donc allé
décidément très vite pour le natif de
valence en cette année 2010 21 création
de la domont sas commercialisation de la
première cuvée et acquisition de ce
bâtiment apporte de savoie donc au 1er
janvier
chômeur retraité retraités sportifs
comme on dit au 1er mars je travaillais
dans nos domaines de nicolas et marielle
j'ai fait toute la saison avec eux et en
parallèle j'ai continué mon ma petite
activité de négociants celle du raisin
sur pied que je ramasse et que je
transforme je fais tout jusqu'à la mise
en bouteille et la commercialisation à
le voir s'activer dans ses caves on
devine facilement qu axel domont
s'épanouit pleinement dans cette
nouvelle vie et entre gamme et jacquaire
ou même mon 2 l'ancien pensionnaire du
chambéry cyclisme formation a choisi de
faire un vin à son image cd20 que j'ai
envie de faire aussi c'est les vins qui
sont qu'ils sont frais qui sont un peu
sur des acidités qui aurait réveillé un
peu les papilles cette reconversion axel
de mon lave est pleinement préparée
alors que d'autres anciens sportifs de
haut niveau ont choisi un certain
confort pour l'heure après carrière lui
a préféré s'orienter vers un milieu fait
de labeur et de conditions parfois
difficiles j'aime beaucoup le mot
agriculteurs et l'important je pense
parce qu'on travaille la terre et
ouais faire quelque chose de ses moeurs
et c'était quelque chose d'important
pour moi et c'est une facilité pour moi
d'être des dehors je me sens bien plus à
l'aise à faire affaire ça qui est
derrière un bureau justement où je suis
pas dans mon élément après une première
année passée dans le monde du vin a
lancé un grimpeur qui compte à son actif
huit participations à des grands tours
semble déjà avoir définitivement tourné
la page du cyclisme professionnel sans
aucun soupçon de nostalgie
voilé puis je vous disais dans les
titres de ce journal c'est officiel
maintenance et april benayoun miss
provence et première dauphine de miss
france qui représentera notre pays au
concours miss monde le 16 décembre
prochain à porto rico amandine petit
s'étant désistés c'est une jeune femme
vous allez voir aussi ravissante que
combattante qui devant la caméra de
jérôme jacob de nos confrères de la
provence revient sur la condamnation de
ce qu'avait poster des tweets antisémite
la concernant regarder les personnes qui
écrivent ce genre de d'obscénité ne sont
pas protégés derrière leur écran et
c'est pour ça que j'ai porté plainte que
j'ai voulu aller en justice était pour
prouver aux gens que en fait
les réseaux sociaux c'est là c'est la
vraie vie aussi et qu'il y a des
répercussions voilà puis quand on
demande à april benayoun 6e concours et
sexistes comme on l'a souvent entendu et
bien la jeune femme de 22 ans monte au
créneau écoutons là et je voulais juste
redéfinir ce qui était vraiment le
féminisme c'est l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes et à partir du
moment où les femmes ont envie de faire
ce qu'elle veut moi j'avais absolument
envie c'était ancré en moi je pense de
fer miss france et ça m'a apporté
tellement de choses que je n'aurais
jamais pu avoir
voilà on croisera les doigts pour april
benayoun pour le 16 décembre prochain à
porto rico et puis pour terminer ce
journal télévisé en beauté voici un peu
de magie à quelques semaines des fêtes
de fin d'année cela se passe à bordeaux
où 500 sculptures lumineuses sont
exposées jusqu'au 2 janvier au parc
bordelais des sculptures que vous pouvez
découvrir sur ces images de bénédicte
dorin de tv7 la chaîne du groupe sud
ouest elle rappelle l'univers d'alice au
pays des merveilles ou celui du magicien
d'oz de bien belles maj en provenance de
bordeaux voilà c'est la fin de ce grand
jt des territoires merci de l'avoir
suivi sur vos chaînes locales et
régionales et sur tv5 monde on se
retrouve bien sûr pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous et bon courage
[Musique]